[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh brad biggs is back
uh covering the chicago bears for the
chicago tribune
uh brad before we were rudely
interrupted the reaction to the city
when
you realize that you're on russell
wilson's final four
yeah i think it was a huge development
bears fans were fired up
the hope for not only the fans but the
team
has to be that the bears being on this
list of four teams that the agent shared
with
adam schefter isn't the highlight
of their quarterback developments for
this offseason because if it is
in there it will probably be
disappointment for the chicago bears at
hollis hall as they try to
uh solve the the seven decade quest
to replace sid luckman but
i'm i'm danny downer today because i i
don't think this happens with the bears
i don't think russ
has traded this year but it's it's
wishful reporting that we have
there's a lot of hope there the uh
realistic
possibility that russell wilson is the
chicago bears is what a chicago bear
is what well i i don't think the odds
are
great for the bears i don't because
you can come up with a list of uh
reasons why it makes sense for the bears
from now until the end of your show
today
i we could bang our heads against the
wall to come up for motivating factors
for the seahawks to to do this trade
seattle has been a perennial contender
with russell wilson on the roster every
season the seahawks are in the mix
it at the minimum in the nfc west
in the conference and in a shot to vy
for a super bowl birth
take him off that roster i i don't know
what they have and and
i don't know how they replace him
in a trade with the bears and and
obviously the bears can't give
seattle a quarterback that makes him a
contender nick foles
won't check that box for them so they'd
have to make a separate move then
to to acquire the replacement i just
don't see it i mean
what would lead pete carroll
down that path i i have a hard time
envisioning it
i'm with you what about desean watson
that
possibility a month ago that was the
topic in chicago
yeah well i think what separates the the
two guys
is that wilson's camp has come out
and put chicago on a list of just a few
teams both of the quarterbacks have no
trade clause
so they can kind of pick and choose a
potential destination
no one has publicly linked
the bears to watson but besides bears
fans right
to this point so i think that's the big
difference
uh there the houston situation
is uh completely discombobulated right
now
i i don't know if anyone has a good
guess when there could be
uh some movement or a development there
both sides are really dug in so i th
so i think that's what separates the two
sure the bears and ryan pace should call
nick casario and the texans two or three
times a week and
until houston tells them to uh to buzz
off
but i don't know uh that that's a
realistic possibility for the bears
either
and again same thing how do the bears
swing a trade with houston
that puts the texans in position to
replace
their 25 year old star quarterback guys
can't can't do that but you know how
this works though brad
we always look at one side of a trade we
don't look at the other side
which is what is seattle getting back
what would the texans get
back it's hey the bears with russell
wilson are they a super bowl contender
and i always go
well yeah they probably would be but
let's get back to reality here
and what is plan b if you don't land
a quarterback via a trade
yeah that that's where you know i i've
said it
it's going to plan c if you have wilson
and watson in some order as a or b
you go to plan c the most intriguing guy
to me
for the bears in that scenario might be
jameis winston
drew brees is yet to retire uh if drew
brees re
somehow returns to the saints i would
think that would put
james in play for a bunch of these
quarterback needy teams and make him an
interesting
candidate is ryan fitzpatrick going to
continue his career will marcus mariota
be
cut and put him in a position where you
don't have to trade to acquire him
from las vegas could they have interest
in
trying to rehab sam
darnold that's sam darnold would be a
risky proposition for the bears from the
standpoint that
the gm ryan pace and the coach matt nagy
they're under pressure to
to win this season the word that
ownership used was that
needed to see progress after consecutive
uh
eight and eight seasons it was another p
word in there if
it's playoffs is what it is brad not not
progress well they got to the playoffs
this year dan they've got to
either win in the playoffs or get into
the playoffs with a uh
much better record than eight and eight
when they when they actually backed into
the thing
is mitchell trubisky bad or just not
good enough
he's just he needs a he needs a fresh
start elsewhere and
the bears need a fresh start and and may
you know we probably need some new
voices
uh in his ear too he works hard
he's diligent it it didn't happen here
he's got a good record he's 29 and 21
as a starter that's a that's a pretty
good level of experience for a guy that
has been in the league for four years
but i but i think he's going to benefit
from a change of scenery but imagine if
the bears didn't pass on patrick mahomes
and deshawn watson
and they they got mitchell trubisky like
later in the first round i i wonder
about the expectation level
i i don't know if that would have helped
well it probably would have helped
i don't know if it would have helped
enough but it just felt like whatever
mitchell trubisky did
it always paled in comparison to what
deshaun watson
and patrick mahomes did and as you know
a lot of times you're compared to the
person that
you were in the draft with like alex
smith and aaron rodgers or ryan leaf and
peyton
manning mitchell trubisky was never
going to be good enough
it felt like right and and
that's why a fresh start elsewhere while
that storyline's still going to follow
him wherever he goes
it's it's not going to be uh front and
center quite as much as it's
it's been here in chicago where they
where they
not only drafted him ahead of watson and
mahomes but traded up to draft them
you know the bears so you look at what
they've invested in the position they
traded a first round pick
two thirds and two fourths to trade up
to get
trubisky and then to acquire nick foles
in a trade a year ago foles is the only
one that remains
under contract for them so it's it's
quite a mess for them right now as they
hope to somehow get better offensively
and win with the defense that they feel
remains playoff ready after a second
half slump
how about this you just don't have a
quarterback brad
no no they don't no but how about we
just don't have one
we just don't have one yeah well uh we'd
have to create some new rules for the
game right or
no just the wildcat just you know i just
okay yeah i just
you know go red grange on them you know
let's just
yeah like because i if nick foles is
gonna be your quarterback or jameis
winston and
like that's not the momentum you want to
have after being a playoff team the
previous year and
it would put them in a position where
there would be little room for air
with the moves that they're going to
make around the position this off season
when you look at the free agency which
opens
next week and then the draft they would
have to be
razor sharp in terms of they brought in
some guys
they made some real value buys they
helped out and they'll have to hit in
the draft
the quarterbacks that are after watson
and wilson are guys that you can win
with maybe not win because of and
therefore
you're going to have to be better around
that position
should be fun but you know tamp down
these expectation levels
right i'm trying to encourage bears fans
not to get too dreamy
tell him to talk about illinois
basketball or zach levine
or i don't know something else because
white sex or
white text might be a good story yeah
that's it with tony larussa the ageless
tone the genius tony larussa
brad thanks for joining us we appreciate
your time have a great day
that's brad biggs he covers the bears
for the chicago tribune